you
[Music]
[Applause]
please welcome the representatives of
the 50th reunion class Columbia Law
School class of 1969
you
[Applause]
I'm Ayesha McHugh hi my name is
Katherine Nunez I'm Marilyn Castillo as
the co-chairs of the graduation
committee we are truly honored and
excited to celebrate with you today we
know that we would not be on this stage
without the love support and guidance of
the many people who believed in us so
before we begin we want to take a moment
to thank everyone who has made this day
possible our family friends educators
mentors faculty and the support staff
that have continuously ensured we had a
safe and clean space to learn in our
friends and family that supported us
mostly and mentally even when we started
using phrases like de novo in res
judicata on behalf of the class of 2019
we thank you for your continued support
[Applause]
it has truly been a journey class of
2019 you might remember that during
orientation Dean Lester told us took to
look to our left and to look to our
right and promise unlike what was
portrayed in the movies we'd all make it
to the finish line
so we'd like to task you with the same
today class of 2019 look to your left
and then look to your right we did it
today marks the beginning of what the
class of 2019 will accomplish to begin
this ceremony please join me in
welcoming jillian lester Dean and Lucy G
Moses professor of law to the podium
[Applause]
Thank You Marilyn
Ayesha and Katherine congratulations to
the Columbia Law School class of 2019 as
you sit today at the center of
Columbia's campus you are surrounded
quite literally by concentric rings of
friendship love community and
opportunity your classmates seated
beside you have become lifelong friends
they've struggled with you lend help in
times of need and become some of your
closest allies beyond them sit your
friend your your family and your loved
ones they're here today to celebrate you
and they take enormous pride in your
accomplishments but they also deserve
recognition from you and from us for
delivering you to Columbia and for their
devotion along the path that led you
here let's give them a round of applause
beyond them lies a stunning campus of
this great University and not just a
physical place but a community of
professors staff and students that's
enriched you academically and personally
and Columbia as you will soon come to
learn is also a community of alumni
today we are joined by members of the
class of 1969 who are here to celebrate
the fiftieth anniversary of their
graduation from Columbia Law School
members of class of 1969
could you please rise so that we can
welcome and celebrate you
and finally beyond the gates of Colombia
lies a great city a place of astounding
opportunity by now every one of you is a
New Yorker endowed with limitless
possibility so as we gather here today
and celebrate your graduation in the
start of a new phase of your lives
cherish the friendships you've built
here honor your loved ones take pride in
the Columbia University community of
which you will always be a part and draw
inspiration from your time in this
incomparable City so great friends great
family great institution great city
that's a lot of greats and in many ways
our world is consumed with the idea of
greatness on an even broader scale we
idolize business leaders who can turn
startups into billion-dollar unicorns we
venerate athletes whose prowess makes
them the fastest strongest and best
among contenders
we love rankings well most of us do of
schools law firms cities even as we know
that they can only tell us so much we
obsess over the daily musings of
so-called influencers who festoon our
social media feeds with tips about
beauty style and Happiness the concept
of greatness it seems is a shared value
of our time transcending identity
geography religion politics now you may
be wondering where I'm heading with this
surely I'm not about to throw shade on
the pursuit of greatness and excellence
am i that wouldn't be so great
would it but in fact I am just just
gonna throw a little bit of shade and
here's why
if we slavishly fetishize greatness
above all else we walk into a trap a
trap of false binaries we risk adopting
a mindset whereby anything short of
winning is by definition losing if we
aren't successful we fail if we aren't
the best we're the worst if we aren't
praised we're blameworthy and while we
may in a sense in our heart of hearts
know that this zero-sum outlook is a
fallacy we succumb to it all too readily
so what's the answer that we all strive
for mediocrity of course not
instead the challenge is to find
excitement in the pursuit and mastery of
excellence while at the same time
rejecting this trap of false binaries
it's one of the most important things
you can learn the ability to hold these
two things in your mind at the same time
a kind of equanimity equanimity is a way
of thinking that allows you to see more
clearly that simple binary scan obscure
truth that life can be imperfect and yet
joyful an even mind one that achieves
achieves equanimity remains unfazed in
the face of imperfection cool in the
face of crisis undisguised in the face
of disappointment and conversely a
tempers you to receive your victories
gracefully with moderation instead of
arrogance or swagger to be clear
equanimity is not apathy
nor is it indifference to the contrary
it demands discipline and attention
but this quality if you can cultivate it
successfully will make you a better
lawyer and a better person equanimity in
the practice of law enables you to focus
on doing the task at hand rather than
fretting over how you will be seen to
have performed it helps you to learn
from others without the distraction of
internal comparison it allows you to
pick yourself up and carry on when you
suffer a setback and it gives you a
measure of humility and humility and
perspective when you gain advantage and
so to equanimity can make you a better
and more engaged citizen it's no secret
that we live in a time of deeply
polarized public discourse or it may be
all too tempting to brand everything
that's not deemed right as woefully
wrong with the space in between crowded
out completely the degree you've earned
today is the culmination of years a
lifetime even of hard work and
dedication when you walk across this
stage you might feel like you finally
achieved a measure of the greatness that
has so long motivated you and you have
so much to be proud of take time to
celebrate it and all the good things
that will follow but our world has a
peculiar way of moving the goal posts
sooner than you realize you'll find
yourself in situations that require much
of you today's feeling of accomplishment
may cede ground to a different set of
ideals and priorities a new and
seemingly more impossible set of
criteria by which to measure greatness
when those days arrive and they will
strive to swim against the currents of a
binary world try to hold your thoughts
in equipoise
finding the evenness of mind to suspend
judgment of yourself as much as others
and resist the temptation to seek to
seize upon simple bromides born of fear
or discomfort that's what will set you
apart not society's version of greatness
but you were equanimity in moments of
challenge and in moments of triumph
class of 2019 the world awaits you I
salute you and I congratulate you
[Applause]
hello graduates friends and family of
the class of 2019
my name is Wil Cobb as the outgoing
president of our Student Senate it is my
honor today to introduce today's
graduating student speakers these two
graduates were elected by a popular vote
of their peers and will speak this
evening on behalf of these two
incredibly vibrant and accomplished
student bodies first to speak for the JD
class of 2019 I am delighted to
introduce Pablo as of iOS
hello class of 2019 there are so many
people to thank for making this day
possible first I'd like to thank the
folks in the facilities department who
built this stage and made sure the
Jerome green hall was a safe and clean
place for us to study in every single
day I'd also like to thank professors
administrators staff and all those whose
work seen and unseen made this day
possible let's give a round of applause
for them the last three years were a
singular time to be in law school it
started off as you might expect the
August Sun beaming on us over the
orientation events and represent Plaza
the nervous anticipation as we sat
through welcoming remarks the brief
exchange of phones to facilitate
Facebook friend requests maybe even a
bomb legal methods cold call we
envisioned the 1l year spent finding our
footing and yearning to fulfill the
sense of mission that brought us here in
the first place yet on one November
night during one all fall uncertainty
became tumult we were bitterly reminded
that the question ohoo that gets to
enjoy the full benefits of citizenship
the bedrock of our democracy and the
legal system we aspire to join remains
deeply unsettled and as we looked at the
outside world we also looked inward we
questioned what it means as lawyers to
uphold the rule of law when allegations
of breathtaking wrongdoing permeate the
highest levels of our politics while
young people awaiting trial languish on
Rikers Island because they cannot make
bail
we listened as many including members of
our own community stood up and declared
me to
all throughout there were some who
learned harsh realities they never
thought they needed to know well there
are others whose voices were finally
being heard and even those who felt as
though they no longer had to bear their
sufferings in silence but amidst the
hurt and the chaos fellow graduates we
rose to the occasion in our midst
class 3:19 our people who went as far as
the southern border to help secure
asylum for migrants including families
who'd been separated from their children
people who were sick of mass shootings
and helped lead the largest march
against gun violence this state has ever
seen people who enforce the rights of
low-wage
[Applause]
people who enforce the rights of
low-wage workers and help secure justice
for survivors of domestic violence
people who successfully defended
low-income people from unjust
prosecution's and sentences people who
testified in state houses in support of
key legislation people who produce
scholarship are new theories to hold
government at all levels accountable for
our constitutional rights and people who
are tired of the barriers facing women
in politics and founded an annual
conference to encourage women at
Columbia to run for office
i watch this channel that same vigor and
generosity of spirit that we had when
facing the outside world right here in
our law school community whether by
sending someone notes when they missed a
day of class listening patiently and
offering sage advice to a friend
contemplating a major life decision
bucking up a classmate whose client
faced long odds in the looming court
date in advocating on behalf of improved
career support in every sector for
future students this is who we are this
is the class I am so proud to be a part
of and this is the class that I have
seen the last three years durable in our
compassion relentless in our advocacy
devoted in our commitment to justice and
I cannot wait to see what we do when we
set loose that spirit upon the legal
world
fellow graduates regardless of whether
the next few years may take us through
pro bono and bar committees advocacy and
perhaps our full-time work each of us
can fulfill the role that Justice
Brandeis prescribed for us over a
hundred years ago to be the people's
lawyer and as we take part in that work
we will face an age-old question should
we fight mainly to secure the victories
at hand or should we be unyielding in
pursuit of a world free from any trace
of inequity or injustice although I
don't propose to resolve that question
tonight I can't help but think of what
others before us did who faced those
same challenges in their own lives
between fighting to make it through the
here and now and fighting for a future
worthy of their highest aspirations and
for me I think about my parents my mom
and dad came to this country from
Ecuador in the 1980s one of dads first
jobs was at the Grand Hyatt back when it
was owned by a certain developer with a
5th Avenue tower that bears his name and
my mom fled the first place she lived in
after she got to this country with
nothing but the clothes on her back my
parents would eventually find steady
work clawed their way to middle
management meat and marry but even as
they found stability and started a
family they'd still make endless
sacrifices all in the hope that my
little sister and I would never have to
hold back from dreaming now I get to
graduate from Columbia Law School and
the same before you tonight
my family's story charts a course for
all of us
in short order we'll get to work with
the world as it is mending the damage of
the last few years and making our
institutions whole but one day long
after this stage is broken down and the
gallons get put away and the diplomas
gather dust on office walls our
communities will live in the world where
their inherent dignity is affirmed where
people have the freedom and the
resources to more fully be the authors
of their own destinies the future may
not belong to us but it is when we
doubtless will help shape that fellow
graduates is our charge rooted in our
history rounded by humility but
unshackled from a poverty of imagination
we pressed forward always holding close
the poet's words that some work of Noble
note may yet be done class of 2019 thank
you and Godspeed
[Applause]
Thank You Pablo and now to speak for the
master of law class of 2019 I'm
delighted to welcome
yonas Verna Minh what is a class of 2019
what is a facial I also want to welcome
all guests faculty members parents
family and friends my name is jonas
venema I'm a proud Belgian and as you
can see European citizen go forth
I am also those people's right in the
back over there I'm also those people's
son and before I start I would like to
apologize for not telling you that this
was going to happen
I also want to apologize for apologizing
in public because I know how much you
loathe being at the center of attention
sorry mama and papa
I coped ignorant knock-knock welcome
enters and please don't run out of your
seats today I have the honor of speaking
to you all on behalf of the beautiful
talented promising class LLM class of
2019 and the honor of speaking to my
classmates dear friends you are truly an
exceptional Bunch the faces of the
people around you glow with great
expectations great expectations for us
children as partners and parents as
lawyers as scholars as leaders they want
you to realize your full potential to be
the best in your field they want you to
be successful to be happy even wealthy
maybe even wealthy or powerful dear
classmates starting today all eyes are
on you naturally we will fail to live up
to these expectations it is true we will
there are only so many cases that we can
win deals we can make brilliant papers
we can rights movements that we can
build only so many hours of sleep that
we can skip more than once we let
ourselves down disappoint our friends
our parents our loved ones and you know
what that is okay it is okay because
true failure does not lie in not living
up to expectations failure lies in not
trying it not disrupting or breaking in
not mending in not improving in not
imagining it lies in closing ourselves
off from the challenges we face it lies
in being blind to the responsibility
that comes with our privilege a Columbia
Law School degree puts the world at our
feet it grants us X's and credibility
credibility that others can only dream
of
people look to and listen to Columbia
law graduates people follow Columbia law
graduates they will count on us to make
the tough decisions
count on us to make the right decisions
but we will have to be vigilant because
too often the law has legitimized grave
injustice --is too often academic
corporate or political culture is used
as an excuse for lawyers actions we can
do better we must we are expected to all
eyes are on you
fortunately a single year at this school
and among these JD's has given us new
ideas better arguments sturdier skills
and a more precise moral compass to face
future challenges most importantly our
time here is embedded in this community
so that we do not have to face that
future alone over the past months we met
like minds mind they liked and minds
that we minded we found people who
understand us
people who get who we are where we come
from and what we care about friends who
recognize the madness of being a lawyer
we made allies who understand who we
love and why it shouldn't matter who we
love soul mates who brought comfort
because they've also been unfortunate I
have also been ill have also lost a
loved one this class our class their
talent made us feel like frauds shams
imposters it was hard at times but it
was the same friends and colleagues
colleagues who helped us overcome our
fears or insecurities they took our
minds off in music movies and plays
showed us their culture in ways they set
us back on our feet sometimes it is
straight they kept us up till way too
late their honesty and kindness set them
apart more than once we asked ourselves
do we really have two parts we do
but you will forever stay a part of this
class of this school that bond does not
end look around from now on wherever you
go someone in this crowd will be there
waiting whenever you are in doubt
someone will be one call away
whenever you fail and you will fail
someone will help pick you up you will
be in our minds we will have your back
we will be looking over your shoulder we
will keep an eye out all eyes are on you
thank you and congratulations
[Applause]
good evening my name is Marilyn Castillo
and I'm honored to present the 2019
Willis Elam Ruiz prize for Excellence in
teaching to the much respected professor
Zohar Goshen the Jerome L green the
Jerome L green professor of
transactional law and the director of
the Center for Israeli study Legal
Studies here at Columbia Law School each
year the law school student body votes
and selects a teacher whom they believe
best embodies the legacy left behind by
Professor Reiss professor Rees was a
member of the Columbia Law School
faculty who is best remembered for his
charismatic style unwavering commitment
to his students and dedication to
teaching not only the letter of the law
but a deeper grasp of its spirit and
meaning the Willis Rees prize is awarded
each year to an exemplary Columbia Law
School professor who exhibits a similar
passion for educating the next
generation of legal scholars and
protection OHS alike professor Zohar
Goshen is one such professor in fact he
is the only third repeat winner of this
teaching prize
[Applause]
after receiving his LLB from Hebrew
University his LLM and s JD from Yale
Law School and serving on Hebrew
University's Faculty of Law for 14 years
professor Goshen joined the Faculty of
Columbia Law School in 2001 as a
visiting professor and became a perfect
permanent professor in 2004 as a
Columbia Law School faculty member he
has earned the reputation for making
corporate law classes accessible
explaining material in a clear manner
ensuring students understand it and
encouraging students to develop critical
thinking skills it is both my pleasure
and tremendous honor to present the 2019
Willis teaching prize to Professor Zohar
Goshen
[Applause]
Thank You Meryl for the kind and
generous words class of 2019 families
friends colleagues and distinguished
guests Wow
few days though ago someone wrote on
LinkedIn that being on stage is like
eating tiramisu it's not it is with
great honor and happiness that I receive
the Willis trees teaching prize I am
extremely grateful teaching is my
passion and I feel fortunate to teach
the best students in the world here at
Columbia I have men I have many reasons
to cherish this teaching prize and I
would like to share with you one of them
in 1949 one year after the establishment
of the State of Israel all the Jewish
people living in Yemen were flown to
Israel in an operation known as magic
carpet
my parents each 20 years old walked two
months to the secret airport to board
the first and only flight of their lives
to start a new life in a new country my
mother may she rest in peace
believed that the road out of poverty
for her five children went through
education she made it our first priority
and every day when she came home from
her job in a sausage factory she checked
our homework it took me until sixth
grade to notice that she was holding the
notebook backwards you don't know how to
read I said
yes she replied calmly and now that you
know you will teach me and she learned I
guess I just would like to dedicate this
wonderful prize to my mother and to all
the parents and family members who
support and encourage us to be the best
we are
thank you when I told my eight-year-old
son here is there that I planned to talk
about my mother today he said why don't
you talk about the people who are still
living and loving you like me mom came
and Nadav here I just did I love you all
and a few words for the road and words
that I believe are the reason that you
have chose me to speak some of you
believe that your talent hard work and
dedication brought you to this exciting
moment well others like myself are
afraid that the register will suddenly
announce though our Gaussian we are
sorry we made a mistake you should not
be here please step aside joking aside
this difference in attitudes reflects
not just different levels of
self-confidence but also different
beliefs about the role of luck in life
after completing my first law degree
against some self-confidence and by the
end of my 20s I believed that 90% of
what happened in my life was in my hands
and the remaining 10% was luck bad luck
but the belief that in real time you can
tell whether something that is happening
to you is good or bad is often wrong
sometimes it takes years until an event
reveals its true nature as either a good
or a bad thing now in my 50s I know that
only 10% is in my hands and 90% is in
God's hands
what are the implication of this
realization to begin with you have to
work the 10% that is in your hands
as if there as if it were the hundred
percent and as you do it just remember
that it is difficult to evaluate
achievements or failures and their
effect on your current or future
happiness dying happiness to
achievements is the futile exercise when
you do that you start saying to yourself
I will be happy when I finish college
when I get into Columbia Law School when
I get rid of goshen when I finish law
school when I make partner when I get
married when I make a million dollars
achievements are a moving target and you
will be doomed to live a life of
pursuing happiness rather than actually
being happy being happy is very simple
and free like enjoying a sunset a child
smile or a joke at your expense work
hard but enjoy the road that is your
life and what about the 90 percent that
is in God's hands you might say there is
no God it is all pure luck and there is
nothing you can do to affect the dice of
course I'm not trying to make you
believe that God exists but you know you
will burn in hell if you don't
[Applause]
but if you believe in any gods even in a
non-religious god how can you affect the
90% my experience has taught me that
there is only one way be a good person
there are many ways to do that embrace
the one that suits you you can do good
in the world through public service or
through being the best litigator in
America or by founding a successful
startup you pay attention to your
conscience and you will realize the way
you were designed to bring goodness into
the word congratulations on earning your
Columbia degree it is an extremely
valuable asset that will serve you
wherever you go I wish you good luck and
a wonderful journey during your life I
will miss you
Columbia will miss you so keep in touch
thank you again for this wonderful prize
and for the honoring me with the chance
to speak with you today thank you
[Applause]
good afternoon
every year Columbia Law School honors a
group of its students for especially
outstanding achievement through awards
selected by the faculty we honor
students for their service and clinics
for their academic achievement for the
writing for their leadership in the law
school community and in the legal world
you all have in your hands the complete
list of our honorees this year right now
it is my privilege to recognize the
honorees for four of these awards when I
announced her name please stand the
Samuel Rosenman Prize is awarded to a
student who has demonstrated academic
excellence in public law courses and
outstanding qualities and leadership in
the law school community this year we
have two remarkable recipients sunayana
Bennington and Hayley Malcolm please
stand
[Applause]
congratulations the Pauline Burman
Heller Prize is awarded to the
graduating student who has displayed the
most outstanding record of achievement
in the service of gender equality as
expressed by their coursework and by
their contributions in the law school
and in the broader community this year's
award goes to Loren Matlock Colangelo
[Applause]
the John ordre no prize is awarded to
the JD student with the highest academic
average in this graduating class this
year's award goes to David Weiser
[Applause]
congratulations and finally the Walter
Gill horn prize is awarded to the LLM
student with the highest academic
average and this year's award goes to
Victoria ting gushing congratulations to
each of you and to all of the prize
winners this year now please join me in
welcoming your class gift co-chairs
jessica choi mahi mahi - phi e Rishabh
horik and patrick Waldrop
good evening my name is Jessica Choi
this year along with mati markings if a
rich parikh and patrick ball drop I had
the honor of serving as co-chair of the
2019 graduation class gift campaign
graduating from an institution like
Columbia Law School carries an immense
responsibility its responsibility to
give back to our communities into our
whole world it's a responsibility to
give back via our time our knowledge our
advocacy in our leadership and of course
monetarily I with with that totally
blanked out on all this that was I feel
like that was really the only thing that
can happen with me coming up here I'm
2lakhs about all of this stuff that's my
problem
really just covers up all of my stuff
anyway I the the class gift is about all
of our class
putting aside any petty differences and
coming together as a class to honor that
responsibility by giving back together
to the institution that made us into the
people that get to walk across this
stage today today we are proud to
announce that nearly 72 percent of the
graduating class contributed to the
class gift
[Applause]
please join me in giving an extra
special thank you to all 53 of my
classmates who decided to volunteer to
donate time to help make this happen and
to the nearly five hundred and fifty
students that donated to the class gift
thank you that's why I have a paper
good afternoon everyone my name is Maha
Maha Desai
it was an honor to represent the LLM
class of 2019
along with Rishabh Devan Parekh we feel
privileged of being part of this amazing
international community that has formed
among our classmates as al-alem's and
the class gift was a great way to show
our appreciation and our gratitude for
this unforgettable year at Columbia Law
School as patrick said we're proud to
commit to commit ourselves in this
long-standing tradition to giving back
to the society did the law school sorry
we would like to thank all students and
especially those people who did not
expect to contribute towards this
parents and student loans it is with
great enthusiasm that we present to you
this role to be in Leicester this scroll
consists of the names of the 535
students who contributed and thank you
for all your support and leadership
[Applause]
hello everyone my name is Katherine
Nunez and I have the pleasure of
introducing our keynote speaker tonight
Xavier Becerra Attorney General Xavier
Becerra was sworn in as the state's
chief law enforcement officer on January
24th 2017 he previously served 12 terms
as a member of the US House of
Representatives and while in Congress he
was the first Latino to serve as a
member of the Committee on ways and
means he has demonstrated a record of
fighting for working families ensuring
the vitality of Social Security and
Medicaid programs and addressing issues
that have in that have a impact on job
generating industries such as health
care clean energy technology and
entertainment attorney general Becerra
was born in Sacramento California and is
the son of working-class parents he is
the first in his family to receive a
four-year degree and his Juris Doctorate
both from Stanford University he and his
wife dr. karolina Reyes are the proud
parents of three daughters Olivia and
Natalia and Columbia Law School's very
own member of the class of 2019
Clarissa with that
with that it is my pleasure to introduce
our 2019 keynote speaker the California
Attorney General Xavier Becerra
[Applause]
Catherine thank you very much and
congratulations to you too Dean Lester
the Columbia Law School faculty and
staff to all the invited guests and
dignitaries I wish to thank you for
inviting me to be with you today I came
from California I thought I would bring
the 70 degree weather I apologize to all
of you those of you who are not from New
York and we're not expecting this but
this is New York right and that's what
makes New York special and so we are
thrilled to be here with you but we
really want to say more than anything
else that we're thrilled to see these
folks in these blue robes more than
anything else in the world 2019 class of
2019 this is your day congratulations to
you we've just heard about some of the
outstanding achievements of many of
these students I have the distinct honor
of being here both as your one hundred
and sixtieth commitment speaker and as a
parent as you've heard so I know exactly
how proud many of you as parents and
loved ones are to see this special
person here in this blue rope today in
fact for me it still takes a little
getting used to being here and I don't
mean just here at this podium I mean
here at a commencement because for my
wife and I it's a new experience to
actually get to see people graduate from
college it's an even greater experience
when you get to watch your children do
that for the first time as well and so
we are thankful to all those who made it
possible for those first-timers to be
here today and to get to live that world
that so many had partaken in the past I
also am thrilled to be here because by
being asked to deliver today's
commencement address it was a clear
giveaway that my daughter had graduated
on time
and boy does she graduate I watched her
nailed it yesterday evening at the balsa
loss a graduation ceremony she was one
of the speakers we learned about many of
the students who are graduating here at
Columbia today we learned about their
many achievements and we learned about
so many of the firsts of some of these
individuals I know that your parents
really want to make the most of this
opportunity being here today especially
if they are like my parents who really
really would have preferred that I've
been a doctor I chose to follow my own
path
and yesterday we heard about a lot of
folks of immigrant background who are
told you should be a doctor and while I
never did get the MD I did make it to AG
representing 40 million people here in
this great country they probably still
would have preferred me being a doctor
luckily I married one and so so did my
daughter I don't know what your parents
dream that you would become maybe a
doctor maybe a techie and intrapreneur
but I'm glad you chose this route you
chose to ensure everyone who wants legal
representation will have it
you chose to protect the presumption of
innocence you chose to give people their
day in court I remember the first and
only time my parents swindled out of
some modest savings years in the making
needed an attorney he meant well
but he was way out of his league
actually he didn't know what he was
doing but that was all that they could
afford there are many options when
you're a construction worker with a
sixth-grade education and a clerical
worker with an accent they put their
trust in him but he couldn't deliver
I couldn't deliver I think I was a
sophomore in college at the time and I
was the closest thing that my parents
had or could afford to legal help I
tried but I really couldn't give my
parents the day in court the day that
they deserved sometimes you fall but
sometimes you don't you'll never know
until you try it that's why you have to
test yourself every day you did it for
three years and here you are now comes
the big test some of you have already
been doing this for well beyond three
years just to get here you went beyond
like me you may be the first generation
American in your family like me you may
be the first in your family to attend a
university or like me you may have been
the first to actually get to finish law
school well let me give you the
well-known secret about firsts they're
better when you chase them don't wait
ask Thomas Edison Sally Ride Sonya
Sotomayor Barack Obama asked the 1980 US
men's Olympic hockey team or that's 2016
Cleveland Cavaliers 2016 Cleveland
Cavaliers I've experienced my share of
first I've been cussed out by a
president
I witnessed 9/11 from our Capitol I cast
votes on war and impeachment
I have sued and beaten a President of
the United States
and as I learned from my parents not
every first will be a success but when
you survive the verbal assault from the
commander-in-chief
there's no insult or intimidation you
can't handle when you're able to
confront the aftermath of 9/11 you learn
to take no threat for granted when you
have to hand the American flag to the
spouse of a fallen soldier
you've been begin to understand and
understand real sacrifice in my nearly
thirty years of public service I have
fallen a lot I fought to stop
discriminatory bans against gay marriage
in 1996 I fought against the Iraq war in
2003 while we passed the Affordable Care
Act in 2010 we came up short in
achieving Medicare for all and when we
passed the DREAM Act for America's young
immigrant dreamers through the House of
Representatives in 2010 we fell for vote
shy of overcoming a Republican
filibuster in the Senate but through it
all I learned the most important lesson
how to fall forward how to learn from
those missteps to try again and to get
get it right the next time around
last month I settled a case against
Morgan Stanley to restore the pension
savings of teachers in public workers in
California who like my parents were
taken advantage of
we recovered one hundred and fifty
million dollars
and the president that California Sudan
beat well we've done it another 49 times
so far California has been almost
perfect in our challenges to the federal
government with more than 30 victories
in our court rulings from several of
those 50 cases when this administration
try to take a woman's right to choose we
sue when this administration try to tell
women they could choose their own
contraceptive we sue when this
administration try to tell us that we
would undercount in the census by
including a question that would keep
people from participating we sued when
this administration tried to tell
Americans patriotic Americans who wanted
to serve their country and we're told no
because they were transgender we sued
and in each of those cases we won a
nationwide injunction to stop the
administration from moving forward those
policies because it is important to
defend those people's rights
that's a lot of cases and it's a lot of
unlawful behavior and in California we
keep leaning forward we are reminded
every day of the importance of solid
institutions the kind that legal minds
coming out of this institution build and
the kind that you need to protect your
Columbia Law family is a storied one
yours is a line of revolutionaries of
nation builders of lawmakers your
Columbia law ancestors wrote the
Declaration of Independence the
Constitution and the Federalist Papers
they built the Treasury served at the
Supreme Court's first chief justice and
occupied the Oval Office
your Columbia family steps up when the
call comes
they helped codify and protect the
rights of the people who call this
nation home writes that we are taking
for granted rights that are disappearing
rights that you are now charged to
defend it's your job to decide what that
means no pressure I know you spent the
last three years studying some of the
most important story cases in our
nation's history and learning about the
precedents they've created and how to
follow them but we must ask ourselves
who set those precedents who were they
made to benefit I try to ask myself
those questions when I see failures of
justice when I became the Attorney
General of California I saw that people
were awaiting trial in jail even though
they hadn't been tried or convicted
simply because they couldn't afford to
make bail that wasn't just as your
fellow alum Chief Justice John Jay wrote
justice is indiscriminately do to all
without regard to numbers wealth or rank
when I took office the California
Department Justice was in the practice
of defending the judges who made those
bail determinations when they were
challenged by the defendants but I asked
my team what would happen if
we stopped defending those
determinations we'd end up up ending the
entire system so we did it and today
California has passed a bail reform law
that says moving forward pretrial
detention will be based on your danger
to the public not the dollars in your
pocket we haven't fixed our criminal
justice system completely yet but that
decision was a powerful reminder to me
and to our state of what can happen when
we considered doing things differently
than the way they've always been done
before I urge you think outside the box
take on new challenges think about
opening doors lean forward fall forward
be the first my parents work day and
night to open doors for me that I
couldn't open for them my father still
remembers the days when he couldn't walk
into restaurants because of the signs on
the doors that said no dogs or Mexicans
allowed so he and my mother made sure I
knew what it was to work that it was my
job to do whatever I could to open doors
for others to make sure people weren't
getting shut out by the law I'm asking
you today to do the same to set new
precedents to open as many doors as
possible
you didn't come this far and work this
hard just to step in line just to read
the signs and do as they say you are
here not just to interpret Authority but
to join in that great Columbia tradition
of questioning it and shaping it of
righting wrongs and rewriting the rules
that's what leadership looks like and it
looks like asking tough questions and
demanding honest answers it looks like
chasing those firsts and falling forward
looks like stepping up to the plate this
country needs more leaders like that FDR
Columbia rgb' Columbia class of 2019 it
needs you to be them today
you've open a new door I can't wait to
see where you all will go from here
perhaps John Lewis said it best a dear
friend and colleague in Congress and a
Civil Rights icon when he said you want
to make change you got to get into
trouble good trouble or perhaps it's as
the dreamers in America who are looking
for the opportunity to come out of the
shadows who public come out and declare
that they are undocumented and unafraid
or perhaps is as the poet Dylan Thomas
once said in a poem or a paraphrase do
not go quietly into that good night rage
rage against the dying of the light
my friends family let us be the first to
congratulate each and every
distinguished member of the Columbia Law
School class of 2019 they are the
leaders of tomorrow they will rage and
rage against the dying of the light
thank you all very much
I am in Konya you Arab on Associate Dean
and Dean of Admissions it is my honor
and distinct pleasure to present to you
the spectacular Columbia Law School
JD class of 2019 Bryan Acevedo Matthew
anchormen Stephanie Atta Makos Michael
Adams junior Delia adiyogi Allen Adkison
[Applause]
Zachary Amran Philip andreal
Joshua and he for she Caroline Armstrong
safe ask her
Andrew a store Asia al do
Jason alman Helene Aziz Oulu Vanille the
by Sofia Bajaj Ryan Baker
Nathaniel bulk David Bohm
Tyla balls are Abraham Bane Paul Barker
Samuel bean Lauren Beck David visor
Preston Bell Ivana Maria Benga chair
[Applause]
Benjamin Bennett Juliana
Lihua Bennington Maddy Berg Lauren
Bergesen Alan Berkowitz
[Applause]
Jessica Bernhardt Alexander Bernstein
David Blackman Jocelyn Blier
Zachary bloomenfeld Alexandra budeau
Anibal TM ski Alisa braver Megan
Elizabeth Brennan
[Music]
Jason Bressler Andrew Brickfield
Samantha Briggs
James Butler Melanie Calero Illyria Sam
I Christina kam bow tie Carlton Cailin
Carney Michael Carson
Lydia cash
[Music]
Melissa Castillo
Mary Lynn Castillo Joseph Catalan Otto
[Applause]
Natalie cha
Chung Chung melon each on Kyle sure Mac
Elizabeth Chang Jung Min choke Jessica
Choi David Cho Quinn Kristi Dennis to
[Applause]
Bethany clerk Sami Cleland William Cobb
Kirk Coleman Frank Kohler Lori
Nicole Collins
[Applause]
Stephanie Colorado will in comes'
matthew Conroy Alyssa Costello Timothy
Kaufman Michael d'andrea Ashley Dalton
Brittany
Davis Erica Davis Michael Davis Samuel
de Blake or Teresa Dern Bach Rajdeep
Dhaliwal min-koo ending
Rodolfo Donatelli Audrey induce sex
Matthew Duffy
Cedric Duke any sacani adata amanda
eller Candice Ellis
[Applause]
Sarah Ahmed Al Jarreau II Brendan in
[Music]
Agatha Ericsson in Ghazi and someone who
she dreaded Felidae Gillian Pharaoh
[Music]
Daniel Federer Shane Pharaoh William
Ferren Tyler Finn slow-mo Fisher Michael
Fisher Daniel Flaherty on Hamidah Flores
[Applause]
Jeanette foster davier foster Livingston
Thomas Jordan Fricks
Jakob Fritz in Tinku uhand david foo
[Music]
daniel fugle sad
Trent food Fuji Victoria fit fit rich
Patrick Gallagher Sophie gambler Megan
Gow Samuel Gelb Rohan George
Jordan Giannone Alison give a sh
Scott glass Reginald Clausen Jacob gacho
heaven got sure I'll look on Silas
father Mark Gonzales junior leg open
Abigail daughter Madison grant Ashley
Gregor Steven Gretz
[Applause]
Eliot run Carol Guerrero Heidi Guzman
William Hancock Riley Hanrahan Duncan
hardik Megan Harewood Natasha horn well
Davis Anika halvah dar Aisha
Avery Heisler Ernesto and nandus Jessica
hey Mark
Rachel Higgins Mitchell Hawkinson
Ryan Homes Alana Horan Achmed Hossein
[Music]
Richard Hughes Nora huppert Johanna Juan
[Applause]
Joseph Eisenstaedt Eric is Kendall
Jackson Sara Jackson I'm kit
Jane Majesty Eve
holla Cory Jansen mousse at Jamal meet
me young G Michael job
[Applause]
Lee Jung Joo Jung Jung Victoria Jimenez
Caitlyn chuckle is Alexander Jones
Cameron Jones he set
why does say huh Shannon calden Jenny ji
hoo and Kong
[Applause]
[Music]
Rasika kannan Matthew Kaplan Caitlyn
karpenko Laura Kiely David Kellum Taylor
calcine Clara Kent
[Applause]
Alison Kim Hanna Kim
Janis Kim Charles clue Kevin Kwai
[Music]
Joshua Koenig Jason Keller Dominica
kabocha Chava Tyler chronic and your
goods
William Kuzma Courtney Lamar Geoffrey
LaRocca Audrey Laie Dylan lee sang Holi
Jennifer Brooke Lee Cates Lee Sun one
lien Michael lemansky
Samuel Levinson later on Olivia Lee
Wendy Lee Han ciao
Lin it is now my pleasure to introduce
to you
yeah Dida Ramos Herbert Dean of Students
to present the remaining graduates of
the JD class of 2019
[Applause]
[Music]
all right let's do this Matthew James
lick trot Alexander Edward Lloyd
Felix Martin Lockman Warren lagering
Carolyn Lowery Armando Lozano Susan Lou
Perry Lumpkin Sarah Lynch Justin Moffat
[Applause]
Ariana Malibu sky yeah Haley
Elizabeth Malcolm David manna down
[Applause]
Olivia Manny Sinclair sorry zine meridia
Claire Marsden
Nicole Louise Masiello Lauren Elizabeth
Matlock Colangelo Sam Matthews
Lauren Maxfield Kaitlyn McGough Aisha
McHugh Margaret zelner
McGinnis John McMurray Thomas fatigue
Andrew Mick water
[Applause]
Elizabeth bridge more Mel guard Tina
mang Andrea Mets Justin Mets Jessica
Metzger Lelaina
Ginobili Sibley been Minkoff Richard
Mintzberg Rashad Muhammad
[Music]
Camila Victoria more Zachary Morrison Oh
[Applause]
UN casona Melania Jordan merabh Goodman
Megan Murphy
Arthur moon schinsky Satoru miles Nagano
Henry Nam Maryam nijem Nicholas NAR
Buddhist Barak I'm sorry Kyle
Nelson Jerome Newton Samuel Nero yes
take your time money Isabella no and in
the squad Katherine Nunez angel Huachuca
[Applause]
Priscilla young said
Nicole O'Donnell Ruth Oh heron Colin
Patrick O'Neil Katherine O'Reilly Jones
[Applause]
Joshua Oh bear max off say jibun de
Icaza pollen bono see Lulu owe me a
[Applause]
William Omer guida a casaya kannada a
wusu a ciao sorry
[Applause]
oh yeah Tola oh yeah me me you're in
pack seunga park
[Music]
Jeremy patashnik shame Patel Allison
pearl James Peterson William Peron
Joshua ping Imani Phillips Zachary
Packer
[Applause]
hello Ana Sofia pornea Thomas Joseph
Blasi though
Michael Purcell shouting chin crappy am
Ramesh
Rachel Ramirez guest ELISA
Rana Daniel Ressler gladdy Sophia's
Becerra
[Applause]
Robert Rhoades Kristin rebate o 1l Riley
[Laughter]
Lindsay rinsed off
Jessica row cat Athena robot Christian
Roberts
Tory Roberts Natalie Robertson Dylan
Rogal in Shane Rogers Andrea Roman
Gonzalez social Honoria Romo Christian
Boyd Ronald Catherine Rooney
Kendra Rosario Daniel Rosenfeld Hilary
Rosenthal Karis Rahman
Monica Ruiz vilapando Shinji Rio filly
waha chart see a deep scar
[Applause]
Matthew science
David Saltzman
Sharon jeez son do Victor Sandoval
Suarez Araya both Xena's arse insta Sara
Snowden Berg
Olivia Schaumburg Sophie shoe it
no la Schwartz Angela
Roberta's Li Luna Sasha CMAC Andrew
Shanahan
[Applause]
Julio sharp
Jennifer sharp Michael sharp sandy Shen
eaching she son hoshin Hasan Siddiqui
ellaby Russia bola Kevin Sims Griffith
Samantha Simpson Ruta Sheena Alastair
Smith Edward Smith
[Applause]
Kevin Marius Smith
Kissin Smith
Cassandra Snider
[Music]
Paulina Sosa shantel Sutherland Matthew
T Sousa
Lauren spring it
catch me Stanley Jets turns jeffrey
stein maximilian elias Sternberg John
Hamel Strauss Paul Stratton Alexandra be
steadwell
[Applause]
Charlie suture Gregory sir
Sam Sullivan Lauren son
sue barb Shippuden Eric tang Sophia Noel
- Ravi Nicholas ternasky Adrienne's
Harbor Margaret Taylor Joseph Louise
Pompeo Teresa Conrad Taylor Kelly - you
can't Toland Emily - Lisa - Kyle Tuchman
[Applause]
Maya you tema Eden oom Fabiola Vanita
Erica Van Horn
a beer Varma crystal Vasquez
Melissa burn Fabiola Vega
[Applause]
Alexei Thomas beetle
Mariah Vitaly Patrick Waldrop Andrew
Walsh Nicole walls
Fantine Wang Jing Wang Roshan Wasim Sara
we to camp
[Applause]
Dorothy Weldon machines oui je dois
Noelle Williams Adam Wilson Maeve Wilson
Albert Wong taylor-wood
Erica whoo
[Music]
Victoria she go June shoe Simone
Yancey Alexander yang Karis ye Tiffany
young Yin you marine Zaldivar Pablo and
Rica set by jaws
[Applause]
Emma Jiang Norman
Jiang Lisa
Xiao Kevin then Brooke Jang Shi when Cho
I present to you the JD class of 2019
and it is my pleasure to introduce Dean
Silvia polo Dean of the Graduate Legal
Studies Program
[Applause]
good afternoon my name is Silvia polo I
am the Dean for graduate Legal Studies
and it is a real honor for me to be part
of the celebration of celebrating our
amazing students so congratulations to
all of you my first task today is to
introduce the candidates for the JSD
Doctor of the science of law degree and
they are not Ron Popat Anna Choi and
Yelena ribbit Cova congratulations in
our on and Elena I now have the great
pleasure of introducing the candidates
for the LLM Master of Laws degree
[Applause]
okay let's go
Gillet Abraham's - Daniela Adler
Pimentel - Archie
Lucas adamite Haruka
Akiyama luis eduardo Alcantar agostina
Alfaro Alma nove Abdullah Al Sultan
Melchor Alvarez de moon Gonzales Magnus
Anderson Sanna Elizabeth Boris
Anna Maria underworld
Michael Hadi angle Karolina are sealed
Campos Victor Manuel Armero Rahul Aurora
Shamir Naveed Arshad Gabriela Bevilaqua
a stuffy Stefan of walk
Alejandro are what you eat Marco's
Barbosa
[Applause]
Mari Rosaline Bahrain achaya Gomez
narleen bhava Edward Byrne a Mito yen
bickersteth Maria Sol Blanco Granada
Annabelle Bonnie phone
Alicia Bowen Nick Boyd cane
[Applause]
Raphael brevis the Toledo not visa Putra
Budi Garrett bull green Tommaso coccioli
[Music]
ed Watkyn
Danielle Cardona Aranda Susana Gomez
Ramirez Mariano Candido da Cunha Fabiana
ho ship a sneaky Passman Ichi Francisco
Carrillo Mussina's Carolina Castro de la
Torre Marlene Cervantes lab Roger Chao
oh yeah you Eduardo Cherise Pavia NEBOSH
a day Chloe
ciao young Chui ah Jung Cho
yeo jin cheol we'd enjoy
Regina chong guang truth and chow
[Applause]
Magdalena Seville's Madero Antoine
Sophie shall seek unto anchovy Victor
Diaz Vieira Clemente no row ecoan
Lorenzo Columba man see Santiago Corcyra
man see Rachel Cortez gomez Natalia Co
Co on Davila Yaron Cove oh now you're
creepy hanwen Sui she out Shuang suey
Alexandria Jamie a custodial Lorenzo see
Martinez the fall
Maria Gabriela Davila Eduardo de
villagarcia o ee yo Nardo de castro
Coelho Christine Genevieve leonardo de
castro lejano mount La fiere the rain
softly Marie Marie Delphi Sonia de la
Fuente Paris
Rodrigo Delgado capture mayor can well
sing Poonam preach Dave Macarena
Fernanda Diaz Christina maria diaz bow
loose
Arushi Dikshit Vivian Christina elvers
[Music]
Alexandre SDA Tov ensue tanto yuan yuan
Fei Toma flamo Marcos foo Nicole free
young feeder born Daniela fridge Gerardo
font Annette Brunel month borg and bert
[Applause]
gouging Stephanie Gosk on Juan Sebastian
Gaviria Carla P Archana Eliza George
Emmanuel Gabri Girgis
[Applause]
Judy today our Deanie Fabian classroom
Lauren and bluesman Manuel Gonzalez
Garza you see a gray leaf Antoine
Mariana Gaeta campy no Ankita Gulati
Raghav Gupta Milton good coughs Kiku
yaps key nor Amina hi dad
[Applause]
[Music]
Diego hammer slag how danyoung stop
Harrell Isabella Daniel Harris Andrew
Elias Hashima Julia Cecilia Henninger
Alan yawn FV Manfred Hine areas unagi
hyung Oh Yankee fan Hong Chan room
Cheung Yee yo Jimbo ho
Jennifer how's Daniel her Chaka
she MJ Annie a shoe
Tracey whoo-hoo Chung who Jing Bao Shing
Huang boolean where does Cardenas
Amy Hutchings Helena Engel ROM masayuki
in we Michael dorita camp arrow Mateos
Rossano Ishigaki Arturo Jacque Rendon
t-bone short a guy Henri file Jones
Rachel Jones prakruti Yoshi Guzzi
Kapadia Jordan Cagan Misaki khaki moto
[Applause]
Pooja Ghanshyam Connie Hisham cantar
Catrin car ami petrol scary class
Lisa Kahala hey hey yeah hey yeah
my apologies Sanna Hallie tear mozzie
[Music]
Miriam gasps hey gorilla
Patricia Corolla defconn codecov ski bo
kyung kim Olivia Kimbrough David noble
say uncle Timothy ESCO saline kanpai son
Tom papa san martn cosa munos Patrick
Watson Stine
[Applause]
Sybil Allah news Thomas Kroger you see
Coco you Hani lauduree Grace and Cornejo
Lazzaro
yeah Chan Lee Sharon chore quli Catalina
Rhiannon Lewis Suja Lee Yong Chi Li
Reina
Tom listen even Lin Chen Yu Lin Fernando
javi Lu hi Jing Li Francisco Jose Lopez
Santi Carrie Sloane Yan Yan Liu Chong
Ling MA Vitor Makapuu all Aveda Ayesha
Malik Kamara Fernanda Marquez dolmas
Maria Jose Martinez Arroyo
ana martinez Valis Alvaro annual Mateo
Alonso Alicia
Matthew Pierre Matson Maria Luisa
Dominique
Domingo Marechal Ricardo Medina rodillas
ignacio holy men disabled rodrigo me
john mayer ooh
Olivia Manhattan enjoy Mitra darshana
mitra johannes mit record
nadie Madani tomas Merriman's sake
Madonna Bernardo Ohanian Montero
Diana Karolina Moreno
Haruka Maureen Diego Muniz Medeco Camilo
Martin Maria Alvarado rasca Nakamura
[Music]
[Applause]
josuke Nakamura Michael Johannes not rot
[Music]
Peter Novick
Daniel Newton Liam Richard Nichols Anna
Nordland er Karolina Nunez Barrera Laura
Oh Brian Thomas uber Steiner in Ghazi
Okita Beth fumiko okamura he'd otama
Umezu Vincent on one Hui Oh
Shira party Shawn can Akash power
Rishabh daveandmarit samarth Raj boo
Kendra Patel Alex and Patterson Doron
pear Ralph here Marcos perilous Machado
[Music]
on Swan travel empiric Lord Pfeiffer
Estelle Murray pickle Maria Camilla
Panera Nerina Camilla pudgy Ani
Finn Roman Paul Wahlberg Agatha Christie
Ramos Fabrizio Rebecca no chikara vowel
Sandra Devo Java Maria Natalia Rodriguez
Pastrana tell young row Bruno Rosenbaum
[Music]
Maria Angela Bruce ah Carranza Tatiana
sad salish Daniela Sanchez Jose Ignacio
Sanchez awoken charm
[Applause]
yacouba's Sarma's Fumihiko Sawada Lori
Chalmers nation
[Applause]
Marcia Joshua Michael silly Harrington
Tatyana Segura de Stefano Stavros
surface - Vishal Sharma Roy sim away any
ASIMO Garcia Barnabas Shimon Malika
Singh Luke sizer Lorenzo Sordi Renzo
Victor Sotomayor Diaz Jose spotted
Aarthi sweetie Ron Jeremy Robert Stewart
Kate Stone row heat suit hirokazu soo a
oka hyung soon
- steena jacala Lea revs car
Naoko takashima shreya Talon J Audrey
Ava Morita so Joshua tang Eric Tilian
Victoria u.s. Shin King Nicholas trout
Clement straight off
sandy is an on Juan Pablo Vargas yonas
journeyman Barbara Vidal Diez our una
visin Hansen
Aruna vision Anthony
Pamela Giselle Viva Santos Angela
Wallace Lara Wallace Zhang Kai Wang dong
zhuo Wang joy Wayne Wang Wei Tao Ronan
Wang Yun Dan Wang Vincent Wong
[Music]
[Applause]
min ji Wu Zi Xuan Korra Wu Shu Allanon
yo suki yo she a
[Applause]
Barnardo's aren hashida Almeida
[Music]
Matthew Gregory zellner Jeffries and Le
Jeune majang CDs Cheung Alexander's and
Dell
[Applause]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen it is my great
pleasure to introduce the Columbia Law
School class of 2019
alright guys before following the stage
party before following the stage party
to the recessional and you can do better
I want it nice and loud you finished
three years or one year degree today
nice and loud throw those hats lots of
energy
[Applause]
you